Trascrizione: Luciana MESSINA
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Quanti di voi ricordano di questa immagine
durante il lockdown del 2020?
Forse a qualcuno questo potrebbe sembrare
solo un semplice e banale quadrato nero.
Eppure, chi frequenta i social network
con una certa frequenza
dovrebbe ricordarsi
che questa immagine diventò il simbolo
del movimento Black Lives Matter
in seguito alla morte di George Floyd
il 25 maggio del 2020.
George Floyd era un cittadino americano
che venne ucciso da un poliziotto
che lo asfissiò tenendo il ginocchio
sul suo collo per 8 minuti e 46 secondi.
L’episodio venne registrato
da uno smartphone
e in pochissimo tempo
fece il giro del mondo.
In tutti gli Stati Uniti si scatenarono
manifestazioni e proteste
contro la violenza razzista
della polizia americana
contagiando anche altri posti nel mondo,
tra cui l’Europa.
E mentre proprio qui dilagava l’emozione
e la voglia di partecipare
a un movimento così storico,
la pandemia era appena iniziata
e per tutti noi
era ancora necessario restare a casa.
Fu così che per la prima volta
i social network
divennero l’unico strumento
attraverso cui dare vicinanza
e solidarietà a una lotta politica.
Chi c’era in quei giorni se lo ricorderà.
Instagram, Twitter e Facebook
esplodevano di nero
e così attraverso quel gesto
milioni di persone sentivano
di stare partecipando
a un momento storico.
L’esplosione di quel flash mob digitale
permise per la prima volta a molti
di sentirsi un po’ attivisti in un momento
in cui il mondo si era dovuto fermare.
O almeno così ci pareva.
Un paio di click e ci sembrava
di aver fatto la nostra parte
per cambiare il mondo.
Il tutto, però, comodamente
dal divano di casa nostra.
Se già prima della pandemia si faceva
fatica a capire in che modo la tecnologia
aiutasse davvero i movimenti sociali,
con l’aumento esponenziale
dell’attività online
è diventato sempre più frequente
sentir parlare di attivismo
e di partecipazione politica in termini
di attivismo da tastiera.
In inglese: “slacktivism”.
Esempi di slacktivism sono ad esempio
condividere un video su Facebook,
twittare un articolo,
firmare una petizione online.
Insomma, attività che non richiedono
troppo sforzo o impegno politico,
ma che comunque ci danno l’idea
di star partecipando.
Fin da quando è nato Internet,
i governi e le multinazionali
hanno promosso l’idea
che noi attraverso la tecnologia
possiamo cambiare il mondo.
L’equazione funziona più o meno così.
Se noi diamo alle persone connessione
e poi gli diamo i giusti mezzi
otterremo maggiore partecipazione
e maggiore democrazia.
Devo ammettere che prima di incominciare
il mio dottorato di ricerca,
anche io credevo abbastanza in questo
ottimismo tecnologico.
Mi interessavo di attivismo e guardavo con
entusiasmo l’esistenza di movimenti
come il Me too, Indignados,
le primavere arabe.
Movimenti che trovavano nella tecnologia
una spinta in più per diventare globali.
Tuttavia...
più studiavo, più mi interessavo
di piattaforme digitali
e meno diventavo ottimista.
Nel 2018 lanciai una campagna in Italia
che si chiamava “Intimità violata”.
Intimità violata nasceva da una petizione
online e chiedeva alle istituzioni italine
di varare una legge
contro il revenge porn,
la condivisione non consensuale
di materiale intimo in rete.
Fu proprio in quel periodo
che cominciai a interrogarmi
sul significato di attivismo digitale.
Perché sì, Intimità violata
nasceva dalla rete,
ma per espandersi dovette andare ben oltre
perché per far approvare una legge
i social network non erano sufficienti.
Bisognava uscire dai loro confini,
sfidarne le regole,
ma soprattutto bisognava
sfidarne i limiti.
Permettetemi allora questa sera
di giocare un po’ alla pessimista
o quanto meno alla realista,
perché se a molti di noi può sembrare
che i social network siano luoghi liberi,
orizzontali in cui tutto può accadere
e tutti possono emergere allo stesso modo,
scopriremmo che la realtà
è abbastanza diversa e che anzi,
le regole, le strutture e gli obiettivi
con cui le piattaforme digitali nascono
possono profondamente influenzare
la partecipazione politica
e anche il modo in cui noi
pensiamo all’attivismo.
Ma facciamo un passo indietro.
Nel mio profilo di Instagram ogni tanto
mi diverto a parlare con le persone,
porre loro questioni.
E un giorno ricevetti questa domanda.
“Sarà stupido, ma ho iniziato a fare
femminismo attivista su Instagram
e non cresco per niente. Come si fa?”
Devo ammettere che la domanda
mi spiazzò parecchio
tant’è che mi misi a pensare molto
al suo significato
perché ai miei occhi
non era una domanda stupida.
Anzi, era una domanda che forse
racchiudeva molte delle inquietudini
che hanno oggi le nuove generazioni.
Perché se ci siamo abituati a pensare
che attraverso la tecnologia
possiamo cambiare il mondo,
allora diventa chiaro
che per cambiare il mondo
dobbiamo entrare all’interno
delle logiche delle piattaforme.
In altre parole, per cambiare le cose
dobbiamo ottenere visibilità online.
Ecco, le persone che hanno visibilità
online hanno in effetti un grande potere.
Possono influenzare
le nostre scelte di consumo,
possono influenzare
i nostri desideri di lifestyle
e possono anche influenzare
i dibattiti politici.
Proprio da questa concezione nasce
l’idea dell’influencer.
Una professione.
Essere influencer oggi significa
basicamente possedere
un proprio canale comunicativo,
una specie di televisione digitale
la cui grandezza e potenza dipendono
prima di tutto dal numero
di interazioni e di seguaci,
o followers, che il profilo ha
e che contribuiscono
a dare credibilità alla reputazione.
Ecco...
Gli influencer oggi sono
assolutamente potenti
e proprio per questo il pubblico
che hanno a loro disposizione
diventa essenziale
per mandare dei messaggi.
Perché quanti più followers avrò,
tanto più avrò visibilità
tanto più sentirò di lanciare
un messaggio e venire ascoltato,
tanto più sentirò
di star cambiando il mondo.
Ecco allora che oggi
per diventare attivisti digitali
si aspira molto spesso
a diventare degli influencer.
La figura di questo attivista digitale
influencer è stata accolta
con grandissimo entusiasmo anche dai brand
tant’è che proprio a metà di quest’anno
una famosa azienda di vestiti
ha lanciato una campagna di marketing
che si chiamava “Activist of Optimism”.
Quello che faceva la campagna dell’azienda
era fondamentalmente selezionare
alcuni profili di attivisti digitali
e proporgli delle collaborazioni in cambio
di sponsorizzazioni sui social network.
In questo modo l’azienda ci guadagnava
in visibilità e reputazione
e gli influencer attivisti ci guadagnavano
in followers, ma anche in soldi.
Il problema di campagne come queste
è che nasce con un obiettivo ben preciso,
ovvero rendere l’attivismo
un lifestyle da comprare
allontanandolo sempre più
da quello che in realtà è la sua essenza,
ovvero una pratica politica.
Questa logica è esattamente
ciò che sottende tutto il funzionamento
delle piattaforme digitali
che usiamo oggi.
Ecco, non credo
vi sorprenderà troppo sentirmelo dire,
ma le piattaforme digitali non nascono
esattamente solo con l’obiettivo
di connettere il mondo
per renderlo un posto migliore,
ma nascono
con degli obiettivi commerciali.
Instagram, Facebook, Tiktok, Twitter
sono prima di tutto luoghi
in cui vendere pubblicità.
E come lo fanno?
Beh, sono stati nominati prima.
Lo fanno tramine algoritmi che attraverso
l’analisi dei nostri dati digitali
sono in grado di conoscerci sempre meglio
per anticipare, influenzare e manipolare
le nostre scelte, non solo di consumo,
ma a volte anche politiche.
Basta pensare alle elezioni americane,
ma anche a quelle italiane.
Gli algoritmi si occupano
di categorizzarci assegnandoci
delle etichette che permettono loro
di inserirci in una scatola o in un’altra.
Uomo, donna, bianco, nero, eterosessuale,
queer, vegano, odia la pizza con l’ananas.
Attraverso queste categorizzazioni
gli algoritmi ci mostrano pubblicità
sempre più personalizzate e in questo modo
aumentano i profitti delle piattaforme.
Ma tornando all’attivismo,
l’attivismo che ricerca visibilità,
deve sottostare alle logiche
delle piattaforme.
La prima regola è accettare
di essere inseriti
all’interno di una visione monolitica
di noi stessi
per poterci creare
la nostra nicchia comunicativa.
La parola d’ordine allora
diventa semplicità.
Si semplifica l’informazione,
si semplifica la nostra identità,
si semplifica la nostra appartenenza.
Perché sui social non c’è spazio per
essere anche altro, mutevoli, cambianti.
Dobbiamo far parte di una categoria,
farla nostra,
diventare dei marchi e diventare
così perfetti canali di marketing.
Un’altra delle illusioni
dei social network è anche
l’idea che possiamo creare delle reti.
Certo sui social e su internet possiamo
conoscere persone e condividere pensieri.
Però in realtà, quello che succede
sempre più è che entriamo all’interno
di vere e proprie bolle sociali.
In inglese si chiamano “filter bubbles”
e partono proprio
dal funzionamento dell’algoritmo
che attraverso i nostri interessi,
le nostre ricerche, i nostri contatti,
ci mostra sempre più persone
che la pensano come noi
e sempre meno opinioni diverse.
In questo modo noi
ci disabituiamo al dissenso.
L’attivismo, al contrario, per vivere,
per esistere ha bisogno di dissenso,
ha bisogno di conflitto,
ha bisogno di scomodità.
Ma i social network non sono disegnati
per avvicinarci alla scomodità
e al dissenso,
sono disegnati per eliminarlo.
Per capire meglio questo punto,
forse è bene ricominciare
dal significato delle parole che usiamo.
Ecco, il titolo di questo Ted
è proprio Restart
e quindi vi voglio invitare a ricominciare
dal significato della parola attivismo.
Attivismo è una parola che contiene
al suo interno un concetto importante.
L’attività.
Quest’attività è stata sempre concepita
come un’attività collettiva,
partecipativa e creativa.
Il focus non era sull’individuo,
ma piuttosto sulla massa
perché il successo di un movimento sociale
dipende dal numero di individui
che decidono di mettersi insieme
per cambiare le cose,
per creare cambiamento politico.
Nell’era di Internet, però, sembra che
questo focus si sia spostato
dalla collettività sempre più
verso l’individuo
e che quest’attività sia diventata
sempre più un’attività lavorativa
proprio a causa delle logiche
dei social network.
Forse vi suonerà familiare la frase:
“Il personale è politico”.
Questa frase nasce all’interno
dei movimenti femministi e sta a indicare
che attraverso la politicizzazione
della nostra esperienza personale
sia possibile comprendere
le disuguaglianze strutturali.
Ad esempio, una donna infelice
nel suo ruolo di madre, casalinga, moglie,
può capire tramite il femminismo
di non avere solo un problema personale,
ma anche politico.
Di nuovo, però,
nella logica commerciale degli algoritmi
siamo passati più che
dal personale-politico,
a il politico e personale.
E questo perché?
Perché per essere attivisti digitali,
secondo le logiche delle piattaforme,
noi dobbiamo appassionare,
dobbiamo creare delle narrative,
fare in modo che le persone visitino
più spesso possibile il nostro profilo
e nutrire l’algoritmo.
Ecco allora che nell’attivismo digitale
ogni lotta viene ripiegata su se stessi
e non è più possibile
evitare di personalizzare
le battaglie per cui diciamo di lottare.
Da qui nasce quello che si conosce
come attivismo performativo.
Nasce quando noi stessi cominciamo
a pensarci come dei brand
e pensiamo di dover guadagnare
secondo i valori che incarniamo.
Quando misuriamo il valore
dell’attivismo dal numero di followers
o dal numero di contenuti
che vengono postati online.
Nasce quando forse l’attivismo
diventa più una maniera di migliorare
la nostra reputazione e piacere agli altri
che di voler cambiare davvero le cose
che non ci piacciono nel mondo.
Arrivata fin qui, e ve l’avevo detto
che sarei stata un po’ pessimista,
ci tengo però a dire che per me è ancora
importante partecipare su Internet
e far sentire la propria voce per
difendere le categorie marginalizzate.
Possiamo fare giornalismo dal basso,
possiamo fare sensibilizzazione,
possiamo fare divulgazione,
anzi dovremmo.
Quello che intendo dire, però,
è che se la partecipazione politica
si arrende ad esistere solo
all’interno dei confini digitali,
non è più partecipazione politica.
Ecco perché nel 2021 credo che dovremmo
ritornare al significato collettivo
dell'attivismo e cominciare a scoppiare
queste bolle che ci stiamo creando.
Che cosa possiamo fare allora
se davvero quello che vogliamo fare
è fare attivismo,
cambiare le cose e aiutare?
Prima di tutto forse smettere
di vedere l’attivismo come una professione
a cui magari associare
anche marketing e pubblicità
e ricominciare a vederlo
come una missione sociale.
Chiediamoci a chi vogliamo dare voce,
chiediamoci in che modo lo vogliamo fare,
ma soprattutto chiediamoci quali sono
i luoghi adatti per farlo.
Perché forse non sempre i social network
sono i luoghi adatti per fare attivismo.
Infine, se quello che vogliamo fare
davvero è andare al di là
di postare semplicemente un quadrato nero
sui social network,
chiediamoci in che modo oggi
possiamo ancora costruire
delle agende politiche solide per fare
in modo di cambiare le cose.
Agende politiche che non abbiano più
a che fare necessariamente
con il profitto e con gli algoritmi.
Io credo che Internet possa ancora essere
uno strumento importante,
ma da oggi è responsabilità di tutti noi
fare un passo fuori dai social network
e cominciare a ribellarci
contro un sistema
che ci vuole sempre più
individui e consumatori
e sempre meno cittadini e collettività.
Grazie!